[ NBC tones play ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-From Studio 60
in Rockefeller Center,
in the heart of New York City,
it's...
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
-Tonight join Jimmy
and his guests...
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
...comedian Preacher Lawson
and featuring
The Legendary Roots Crew.
♪♪
-♪ Yeah! ♪
-And now, here he is,
Jimmy...
Fallon!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey, hey,
hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey, hey,
hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey ♪
-Thank you very much.
-♪ Hey ♪
-♪ Hey, hey, hey ♪
-Thank you very much.
♪♪
Oh, my goodness!
I love you.
Welcome.
Welcome, everybody!
Ah, enjoy yourself.
Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You're watching.
Thank you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, let's get
to some news here.
The FDA just announced
that they're banning
Juul e-cigarettes and now vapers
are rushing to hoard them.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
Well, they're rushing,
but stopping every few feet
to catch their breath.
It's like --
[ Laughter and applause ]
But, you know,
I don't like to judge,
but if the terms vaper
and hoarder apply to you,
maybe it's time
to do some reevaluating.
I'm just saying.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, vapers are going nuts,
trying to find Juuls
for your goth cousin.
This is basically March 2020
all over again.
It's like --
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news --
it's a big movie weekend.
"Elvis" is out this weekend.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Pretty big.
Another movie, called
"The Black Phone,"
just hit theaters
and it is a horror-thriller
about a psychopath known
as The Grabber.
-Mm!
[ Laughter ]
Actually, The Grabber sounds
like a product
your grandma would buy on QVC.
You know,
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I think I need that."
That's right, The Grabber is
the terrifying tale
of your friend who eats
French fries off your plate.
It's like --
[ Laughter ]
"I don't like --"
Well, according to a new study,
nasal swabs are still the most
effective way to test for COVID.
Yep, while the worst way is
to breathe on your friend's face
and go, "Does this smell
like COVID to you?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some business news --
the company that makes Oreos
is buying Clif Bar
for almost $3 billion.
[ Oohs ]
-Wow.
-They offered to buy
Nature Valley bars,
but the deal
completely fell apart.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheering ]
-Come on!
Come on!
Come on.
Crumble.
-[ Laughs ]
Hey, I saw that, in Ohio,
a semi truck hauling cheese
caught on fire.
[ Oohs ]
Look at that.
Luckily, five minutes later,
a wine truck tipped over
and it turned into a delightful
little afternoon.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Speaking of wine, I read that,
due to inflation,
wine pours at restaurants
are actually getting smaller.
[ Ohhs and booing ]
You can tell there's less wine.
Now, when you turn on
"Real Housewives,"
they're discussing whether
Ukraine should join NATO
[ Laughter ]
and you go, "Hey, that's --
Come on."
Guys, I heard the FDA actually
approved the new hair loss drug
that regrows hair.
Did you hear about this, Tariq?
-Yeah, yeah, I took it
and it totally worked.
-Um --
[ Laughter and applause ]
It did?
-Yes. Look, I grew this
long, luscious
[ Singsong ]
rat tail.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Don't you just love it?
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Crumbling ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-♪ Hey, Moe, hey, Moe ♪
-♪ Hey, Moe,
hey, Moe ♪
-♪ Well, I nyuk nyuk nyuk nyuk ♪
-♪ Nyuk nyuk nyuk ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Let's
never speak of this again.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Deal.
[ Laughter ]
-Were they dancing?
-What's that?
-What were they doing?
Three writers were dancing
by cue cards.
-There were dancing
to "The Curly Shuffle,"
by Jump 'N the Saddle.
[ Laughter ]
[ The Roots play ]
-♪ When me and my friends,
we go out on the town ♪
♪ We can't sit still,
we can't sit down ♪
♪ We don't like to fight
and we don't like to scuffle ♪
♪ We dance all night
doing the Curly Shuffle ♪
♪ Hey, Moe, hey Moe,
hey, Moe, hey Moe ♪
♪ Nyuk nyuk nyuk nyuk nyuk ♪
-♪ Nyuk nyuk nyuk nyuk ♪
-[ High-pitched scat singing ]
-Okay.
[ Cheering ]
I mean, how do I know
every single word?
-How do they know that,
comedy writer?
[ Laughter ]
-That was a great jam
right there, man, yeah.
-I'm glad you explained it.
-That's what was happening.
So, Tariq showed his rat tail.
-Right.
-Everyone had such a freak-out
that the writers,
they started drinking
and dancing
to "The Curly Shuffle."
-Right, by the cue cards.
-By the cue card.
-It was so crazy.
Tariq's rat tail was so crazy
that they went --
I turned into stone and died...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-...you burned your hands
severely with coffee,
and they started dancing,
having a party, drinking.
They loved it.
They're dancing --
[ Laughter ]
-They had a great time.
It sparked something.
We might take that part out.
-Alright.
Well, no, no, no, no! Come on!
[ Ohhs and nos ]
-No, not the whole thing,
just the guys dancing.
-Don't be a jerk.
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-But you guys didn't even laugh.
-They loved it!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-You guys hated it!
-No!
You didn't like that!
-[ Laughs ]
-Stays in the picture.
It stays in the picture.
-"The kid stays in the picture.
-"The kid stays in the picture."
-The kid stays
in the picture."
Alright, let's get
to some other jokes
that won't be as funny as that.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, guys, this is going viral.
A woman on TikTok said that
she uses the washing machine
to clean her vegetables.
[ Crowd groans ]
Her family only got worried
when she started
folding her vegetables
and putting them in the dresser.
There you go.
Guys, you know, there's a lot
going on in the news right now,
but instead of me
just telling you all about it,
I thought it'd be nice to
just give you the chance
to decide what we talk about.
That's right. It's time for
"You Pick the Joke."
-♪ You pick the joke ♪
♪ You pick the joke ♪
-So here's how it works.
I'm going to show you
two news stories,
and then you guys get to pick
which one we talk about.
Okay? Here we go.
Let's take a look at
story number one.
-President Biden is urging
Congress to give Americans
a tax break at the pump.
-Okay. Here's story number two.
-Some residents of
a Tampa apartment complex
had a very unusual experience
just a short while ago.
Witnesses say a naked man
pulled the fire alarm,
then sprayed residents
with a fire extinguisher
as they exited the building.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-What?
-[ Laughing ]
-Wow.
-Alright, which story do
you want to talk about, 1 or 2?
-2!
-Alright. Good choice.
Okay. That's right.
A naked guy in Tampa
pulled the fire alarm,
then sprayed people with a fire
extinguisher when they came out.
So I guess even though
he retired,
Rob Gronkowski is
still living in Tampa.
[ Laughter ]
Let's do another
pair of stories.
Once again, you guys get
to pick.
Here's story number one.
-Today, the Federal Reserve
took aggressive action
to tackle the fastest inflation
in four decades.
-Got it.
Now, here's story number two.
-Milk, eggs, and this?
Tesia Britt tells
"The Problem Solvers"
when she opened her bag
of delivered groceries
from Walmart,
she couldn't believe
a crack pipe was packed inside,
right next to the pineapple.
-Which story do you want to
talk about,
number 1 or number 2?
-2!
-Great choice.
That's right, a woman's Walmart
delivery included a crack pipe.
Normally, if you want crack
at Walmart,
you just raise your eyebrows
at the cashier.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, let's do one last
batch. It's your choice.
Here's story number one.
-There's a new poll out showing
President Biden's
job approval rating has dropped
for a fourth straight week.
-And here's story number two.
-An Indiana man finds something
a little fishy
after catching a catfish
on the Ohio River.
When Hoop cut open the fish,
he found
a foam ball and an adult toy.
[ Laughter ]
-Story number 2?
-Yeah!
-Great choice.
That's right, a man found
a sex toy in a catfish.
It was the first fishing story
where nobody wanted
to hear how big it was.
[ Laughter ]
-Catfish.
-[ Laughter ]
He got catfished, yeah.
[ Laughter ]